bonjour bruno daroux au jour florent cet
accord sur les céréales il fonctionne
dirons nous mais un petit rythme oui à
petit rythme alors c'est déjà très bien
à ce qui avait été obtenue fin juillet
lors de cette médiation déjà de la
turquie sous l'égide de l'onu on se
souvient que les russes et les
ukrainiennes c'était étaient présents
mais ne s'étaient pas rencontrés quand
même simultanément en face à face mais
néanmoins cette réunion avait accouché
de ce fameux accord sur les exportations
de céréales est depuis le 1er août il y
a eu effectivement un début de reprise
de d'exportation de ces céréales on est
autour de 300 400 mille tonnes de blé
sur une vingtaine de vraquiers comme on
les appelle un ces navires spécialisés
qui transporte le blé qui ont pu quitter
donc le port d'odessa notamment il ya
deux autres ports en ukraine d'où
partent ces navires donc c'est pas mal
ça fonctionne mais effectivement c'est
quand même un petit rythme quand on se
souvient que dans le port d'odessa il y
avait 25 millions de tonnes qui étaient
coincées dans les silos de plus début de
la guerre bon là il y en a à peu près
400 milles qui ont pu partir et qu'il en
reste beaucoup donc ça c'est pour le
stockage à odessa parce qu'il ya la
prochaine récolte qui va arriver bientôt
et puis surtout pour les pays qui
attendent ces céréales ça ne va pas
assez vite pleins clairement puisqu'on
estime qu'aujourd'hui il ya un peu plus
de 300 millions de personnes dans le
monde au proche orient en afrique en
asie quand même qu'ils sont en situation
de risque alimentaire à cause du fait
qu'ils ne reçoivent pas suffisamment de
céréales on l'a dit bruno si les trois
hommes vont parler nucléaire après le
président français emmanuel macron sais
c'est au tour du secrétaire général de
l'otan de demandé l'inspection de la
centrale de zappos rydia par l' ua cette
centrale on en a beaucoup parlé sur
notre antenne elle est actuellement sous
contrôle russe il sera aussi question
d'une solution politique au conflit
vaste programme dirons nous oui alors
vaste programme alors très certainement
concernant le le problème de la centrale
de zap aurait déjà les trois hommes vous
on va en parler ensemble avec
effectivement toujours les les deux
propositions en fait qu'ils sont sur la
table concernant apport est déjà la
proposition d'un retrait des troupes
russes loin de là de la centrale
nucléaire et puis effectivement comme
vous le disiez la proposition peut-être
même en simultané avec un retrait des
troupes militaires se seraient même
l'idéal d'une mission de laguiole agence
internationale pour l'énergie atomique
qui viendraient constater les éventuels
dégâts dans la centrale nucléaire donc
les trois hommes vont en parler mais
sans les russes voilà ça ne vous aura
pas échappé mon chat florent il n'ya pas
les russes donc est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
va beaucoup avancé les turcs vont sans
doute recueillir les propositions les
déclarations des ukrainiens et de
monsieur intéresse et puis vont
transmettre un aux russes puisque les
lectures que se pose en médiateur
et pour le moment je joue très
habilement cette carte notamment dû à
leur situation géographique
mais il n'est pas dit franchement que ça
évolue là tout de suite aujourd'hui mais
ce qui est clair c'est sur cette
centrale de zap aurait déjà on sent que
les positions bouge un peu de part et
d'autre les ukrainiens au début ne
voulait pas d'une inspection de l'agoa
pas ce qu'il disait ce serait
reconnaître dé facto une occupation
russe de zaporijia est donc une
souveraineté russe sur ce territoire de
la centrale bon sang que les choses sont
un peu en train de bouger mais tout
n'est pas encore calé quoi et on
rappelle que c'est la plus grande
centrale d'europe installé vendeuse
apories dia en ukraine merci pour tous
ces éléments bruno